In this lesson,
we're gonna look at creating masked materials.
So let's get started.
Now, when we talk about masked materials,
I'm specifically in this particular class,
talking about masking textures within the material.
So there's a couple of ways in which you can do that.
One of them is we can bring in a texture
with a particular value
and in there connect other textures
to be able to make it look like it's separated
and it looks like two different elements.
Another way to do it also is using the RGB channels
and each RGB channel has a particular texture value.
In here, you'll see in the red channel, there's some grunge.
The G channel is a texture we could use
for bump or height.
The A or alpha channel is used
with different alphas present.
And finally, the all RGB combined all together
gives us some simple generic texture values.
And this is really up to you how you wanna do it.
And we'll explore this last one later
where we're mainly gonna be focusing
on this one where the textures are being masked
within the material itself.
So I'm giving you the steps for each one,
but let's go ahead and jump into Unreal
and I'll walk you through this process.
So in this scene, we have a masked texture.
This one has wood and it has gold
and you can actually see the values change
as I move the camera around
and the light reacts differently
to each part of the textures represented.
A lot brighter hotspot when it comes to the gold,
a lot finer, more sharper reflection
as like a waxed floor for the wood.
And I'll show you how to get that going.
Let's go and open up and take a brief look
at that texture.
I'm gonna point out some things
where you can do some little bit of editing
when it comes to the texture,
if it comes in a little bit imperfect.
Now, I have it all set up here.
And again, this sample is available
for you to take a look at
and I'm gonna walk you through this.
But I wanna point out in this particular texture
when I originally made it,
which was quite a long time ago,
there was a little bit of impurities in my alpha.
Like there was some little bit of spacing,
wasn't really super clean like I wanted,
but that's actually, you can fix that,
believe it or not a bit in Unreal.
So if I double click on this texture,
you'll notice that it doesn't have
the generic compression settings.
If I hit return this value,
they may have fixed this
cause I did this a while back.
I don't wanna just be here to be aware about this tool.
If I tell it to go back to its default,
because the one that I have is BC7 DX11 option eight,
optional eight, put that back and then I hit save.
If we go into our scene,
you'll notice that there you go, you'll see it.
There's some imperfections in the alpha.
Ooh, not really great, right?
But if we go back to what I had,
which was the BC7 DX11 option eight for the compression,
this is gonna give me
a little bit of a smoother transition with that alpha.
And I'm gonna hit save
and now if we go back to simple masking,
you can see it looks a lot better.
It's cleaned it up a bit, pretty great.
So you do have a little bit of tools at your fingertips
to be able to maybe fix some things on the backend.
It's actually not too shabby.
Okay, so now let's go ahead and build this in Unreal.
So I'm gonna go to the content drawer for a second
and I already have a M masking demo.
And again, you can make your material any way you want.
There's a quick way to do it.
I'm gonna double click on it.
Let's go full screen just for a moment here.
We're gonna need to bring in some textures
and we need to pretty quickly.
So one way you can find what we have for you,
we have under base assets and in here we have textures
and you'll find the floor of what we initially need.
So I'm gonna go and grab all of these
and pull them into Unreal.
There we go.
We also are gonna need the gold texture.
So we can find that actually in Megascans.
So let's go to Megascans really quick.
Under Megascans, we'll go to surfaces
and we're gonna go to gold.
Really what we're gonna need is the albedo.
We're going to need the rough.
And then finally we can use the normal.
Now the normal is really nothing to write home about
as well as metal.
Don't wanna forget that one.
The normal is really nothing to write home about
but this will allow us to look at some separation
and some tools to be able to fix normal differences
because the wood does have a normal
and it's very specific
and I'll show you how to blend those.
So I'm gonna pull all these four little guys in here.
There we go.
All right.
So let's go ahead and set up initially our albedo.
So I'm gonna go ahead and move this texture over.
This is the one that we need as well as the gold.
So I'm gonna move these a little bit back just a tad
and we're going to need this guy.
This is going to be our, do it one at a time.
There we go.
And we can collapse that.
We're gonna need this guy.
This is gonna be a little masking texture.
Now again, at any time, if you wanted to
you can invert this.
You're like, oh, dang it.
Wasn't paying attention and I did it the opposite way.
So for lecture purposes, I did it incorrect
just so that I can show off
and show you the one minus note.
So that one minus note allows me to flip that effect.
So I can pull this in.
I can open this up the little arrow here.
And that arrow allows me to see a preview of that.
Hey, look, it's become a negative version of itself.
That's super helpful.
Especially if you need to make a change like that.
Let's get our gold texture.
We're gonna pull it up here
because this needs to come into play
and let's go and make a multiply.
So I'm gonna drag this execution string
into the A of the multiply.
I'm gonna grab that one minus execution string
and bring it into the B of the multiply.
We can see ahead of time by clicking on the arrow
what we're getting.
And we see the gold is in the trim and in the diamonds.
And that's kind of what we want.
We now are going to create an add note.
Now keep in mind the multiply and the add note
are very different from each other.
So if we flip these
we're gonna get different results.
It is similar like I said in the first class
like in Photoshop where they react
kind of like an add and a multiply
in Photoshop's filtering and blend types.
So I'm gonna go ahead and grab this texture sample
put it into the B channel.
I'm gonna grab this multiply and put it into A channel.
We can see what we're getting ahead of time
by clicking down.
And hey, that's what we want.
I'm gonna pull that execution string down to the base.
There we go.
We got our base.
Now, if we want to dumb down the specular
say we don't want those highlights right now
and we want it to be derived from the metal
as well as a rough.
Again, we can right click in here
and say promote to a variable for specular
and keep that at zero.
And you can see it's relatively flat and that's okay.
That's really up to you
if you want to push that a little bit farther.
But if you did use a specular
and you only wanted the specular to be highlighted
on particular regions, again
you'll have to use the same process I did here
where we're using the one minus
and we're going and we're masking things out.
All right.
So now what we need to do is let's go ahead
and build our roughness and metallic.
So metallic still is first up to bat.
So let's move this a bit down.
We'll get to roughness in just a second.
Let's go to the gold metallic and put it here.
And I'm gonna keep my finger the L key.
We're gonna use the lerp node.
Now the lerp node,
I think we briefly talked about it in the first class.
Lerp node again, works like a nice little 50-50 blend
when it comes to working with two different values.
And it comes with an alpha
in which we can control the range, look and feel.
In this particular case,
we're actually using that alpha to help with the masking.
So I'm gonna grab this texture here
and pull it into the each channel of the lerp.
And I'm going to grab that checkerboard texture again
and we're just going to control D, pull it down here.
So we don't have a noodle fest.
And I'm going to also grab the one minus control D,
pull that down.
And I'm gonna connect that RGB into that one minus.
And I'm gonna put that into the alpha.
Now again, you can preview this at any time.
You can see what you're getting.
You can see it's nothing to write home about.
But oops, I made an error.
I put my RGB for the gold on the A channel.
Let's put it in the B channel because they do matter.
Because when you do do that,
you will get different results as they are blending,
kind of like top to bottom in a way.
So if I keep my finger on the control,
this is an excuse to give you this ability.
If I keep my finger on control
and hanging right over that execution point,
I can drag that into the next B slot.
And aha, you see it has changed.
It is now doing what we intended,
all because we rearranged it according to the stack.
And finally, if I keep my finger on the one key,
we just need a simple value to put in here.
So that's something we can change later.
We don't really have a metal value,
but we want to take advantage of that alpha.
So I'm using the lerp
and I'm just putting a simple value into the A slot.
This is really up to you.
Now, again, chairs are actually not chairs, but wood,
in this particular case is not metallic.
But if you just wanted a little bit of metallic
value in there,
you can do so by putting in an actual texture
or actual number.
I'm going to pull this up into metallic slot.
There we go.
Now it doesn't look anything to write home about just yet,
but we're going to get things a little bit cooler
because that rough is going to help a bit.
Now, and you can actually see a nice metal sheen.
If you look really good, you can see a bit of it there.
And again, all these guys are going to come together
like the Avengers and work with each other
and help things out.
So now what we want to do is get the rough crafted
and we're going to use you the same process.
So let's go ahead and borrow some things.
So I'm going to get my wood rough
and my gold rough in the right spot.
I'm going to hit that L key
to get that lerp back in again.
And I'm going to pull in the RGB for the wood
and put it on the A channel
and make sure you're consistent
as you know where things go
and how you want things to look.
And then I'm going to put my gold.
And what I mean by that is
if you're going to put gold in the B channel of lerp,
make sure it's there for everyone.
And then I'm going to grab this here,
one minus and put it in the alpha.
And again, we can see a preview.
What does that look like?
There you go.
That's our intention.
And now we're going to pull this all the way to our rough.
Ooh, look at that.
That looks great.
It's going in the right direction.
Kind of like our intentions.
Now at this point, if you wanted to,
you could pull in specular and say,
you know what, I'm going to make this 0.5
like the default.
And hey, you get a shiny floor.
And believe it or not,
even though we have specular in there,
our rough is still being honored.
So you do need to be careful though.
Sometimes spec can mute rough and vice versa,
depending on your values
and what your intentions are,
they may not come out the way you want,
but this actually comes up pretty good.
Putting just a half specular in there, a 0.5.
Now let's go ahead and round things out here.
And we're going to go in here
and do a little bit of normal.
I'm going to introduce you to a new type of node.
And I don't think we talked about this
in the first class.
So I'm going to go in here and grab those normals,
pull them over.
And now what we can do is two things.
One of them, I can do the same process where I have a lerp
and in here, I can grab that texture that we had before.
Control D.
And I can, if I want to,
I can one minus it and plug these all within the lerp
like we did before.
Another way we can do it actually works pretty well.
Let me move these out of the way
because it's going to honor two different normals
and they're in the right spot texture wise.
I can go in here and create a blend.
This is a material function again,
blend angle corrected normals.
And this actually is a bit more efficient.
And what I mean by that,
it honors one normal change into another
and it blends them pretty well so that the edges
and the differences in how the angles are created
and corrected according to where the camera's positioned,
it actually makes it so it has a nice transition.
So it doesn't look too harsh, obscure or sloppy.
So our base is going to be our wood.
We want our wood to be our background
and then our additional normal is going to be our gold.
And then now we're going to add that.
And it's not like a huge difference here
just because the gold doesn't really have
a lot of normal value.
But if you're working with other things,
this can be very helpful,
especially with one stronger normals.
I'm going to put that in the normal there.
Cool, if anything,
it highlights a little bit of the edge more
between the differences between the gold on the floor
and actually works pretty well.
And we'll hit apply.
There you go.
So we've just masked out using a simple system here
of lerps and we're not even using a masking component,
which is something different we get into another classes.
But in here,
we got these all masked out and have two different
textures that make it look like two different materials
on top of each other, pretty neat.
Another way to be able to do this is using your RGBs,
which I mentioned earlier.
And you can embed this right within a texture.
Let me show you what I mean.
I have a texture set up in Unreal
that we can take a peek at.
In Unreal, you'll see three different types
of texture values and looks here.
And all of these are actually within one texture.
I have a rough here and I have another one here,
which is working in another color channel
and another one here,
which is working in another of those RGB color channels.
And let's actually look at that up close.
So if I double click on the material,
you'll see that I'm using my red channel
for my roughness and my B channel for my base color.
If I wanted to,
I could even do base color for my,
using the color that I have placed in here.
In this layer in Photoshop,
I can color that any way that I want.
I did it super generic,
but you'll see if we do flat,
you'll see I've just have some just simple green
and blue and those can be anything that you need and want
and you can even mass them out like you saw me do
on the last little demo.
So all of this is up to you.
It just depends on what you have.
But the nice thing about this is we also can go in here
and say, hey, you know what?
I wanna do the metallic to be green, you know,
and I want, hey, no, maybe I want that to be blue instead.
You can actually tweak these out and play with them a bit,
but let's look at the texture up close
and I'll show you what I'm talking about.
So this, I'm gonna turn all the RGB stuff off.
I'm gonna zoom out a little bit.
And if I click on my alpha,
you'll see I have an alpha texture embedded in here
and I could use that within a one texture
or in one material.
I have a blue channel here.
So in this blue channel, I have a black and white values
we could use for height or we can use for bump.
We have a green one in here,
the same or some other intention
and the R channel, I have rough.
This can be our roughness or dirt
or whatever it is that you wanna use it for,
it's available.
So it's actually really cool to be able to have this
because then you can plug and play whatever you want.
So I'm gonna disconnect this one
and you can simply just Alt click, left click
to get rid of that if you're not aware of it.
And then we can change these any way that we need.
There's like even emissive,
maybe you want emissive in there.
It's all within this texture
and then you don't have to load several different 4K,
8K textures, you can actually work off
of one particular texture that's packed accordingly.
But keep in mind when you do this,
you have to plan ahead of time
because you have to be very deterministic
and very strategic when doing this.
You need to know exactly what you're going for.
Here's a link to some other resources
you can take a look at,
which will point you in the right direction,
looking at how to mask your textures
as well as one of our former employees, Tor Frick,
who has an amazing demo from way back
in which he's only using like three textures.
It's actually pretty cool.
And he's masked them accordingly using those RGB channels.
Well, that's it for this lesson.
In the next lesson,
we're gonna take a look at material functions
and I'm gonna show you how to build one for yourself.